we got work to do spiderman no way homes
right around the corner i can't watch or
talk about that movie without first
revisiting and talking about this one
first letting you know right out the
gate this video was brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build your online presence and run your
business going to talk about that a
little later but first we procrastinated
enough the time has come
[Music]
so spider-man 2 came out in 2004
directed by sam raimi it's the sequel to
the 2002 blockbuster smash sam raimi's
spider-man at the time held the record
for highest grossing opening weekend of
all time so needless to say among me my
fellow cinephiles out there we spidey
fans the excitement was off the charts
for this one when spider-man 2 came out
it was just the conversation was it is
hands down the best comic book movie out
there ever made i mean granted it was
back when comic book movies were still
kind of niche it's not like they were
the spearheads of cinema but it
definitely was like spider-man 2 and
other comic book movies that are still
great but dude spider-man 2 was awesome
there's just no other way to say it it
was it's one of those movies that
actually gets better the older i get the
more i appreciate it on different levels
because quite frankly a lot of the
swings it took it absolutely knocked it
out of the park there's a lot that works
with spider-man 2. exciting action
sequences check compelling and
interesting character storytelling
showing peter parker and the
difficulties of balancing his life as
peter parker and spider-man check harry
osborne becoming more obsessed with
spider-man thus paving the way for him
becoming the next green goblin check but
right i didn't feel much of the payoff
in the third movie with that but in
terms of the second movie and taking him
to the next phase of that absolutely
nailed it in spider-man 2. layered in
compelling villain and dr otto octavius
who's a sympathetic villain if not a
victim of his own genius check but among
all of this this next one is the most
important takeaway of spider-man 2. i
can't stress this enough spider-man 2
was the moment we learned sony
spider-man trailers absolutely
positively spoil the movie let's use
behind the mask
why would they show that in their
trailer
i thought that when i first saw the
trailer i think that now it's like
they've been trying to outdo that ever
since they're like all right we gotta
beat that one time we totally spoiled
spider-man 2. all right let's just keep
doing that with movie trailers first off
what are we coming for you know
spider-man action sure actually this
movie is much more layered than that but
it being a spider-man movie yeah i'll
talk about the action though to its core
it's absolutely positively a character
piece but spider-man action movie right
we love some spider-man action this
movie has some great spider-man action
sequences some of the best among
live-action spider-man absolutely also
iconic there's some iconic imagery in
this movie that scene where he's trying
to stop the train i have seen moments in
other spider-man movies video games
animated movies they'll throw back to
that moment it's a very iconic scene you
know what the thing is for me like the
nitpick the gripe is the fact that doc
ock takes more than a punch from
spider-man because it wouldn't happen it
would just be one punch
good evening in today's news dr otto
octavius is in a coma after suffering
one punch from spider-man it's unknown
as to whether or not the good doc will
come out of this coma but if he does the
doctors say and i quote chewing solid
foods will be a distant memory i don't
care it's a thing that makes me chuckle
because it is funny but also there's so
much more to love about this movie i
don't give two [ __ ] an important thing
that this movie did for me like i never
saw doc ock as one of my favorite
villains and never saw him as i mean
you're going up against green goblin
venom carnage you know as a 90s
spider-man fan so venom and carnage were
absolutely on the top of that list green
goblin as well you know there were other
spider-man villains i liked so when i
heard doc och was in this movie i was
like okay we'll see it's not going to be
better than the goblin then that first
teaser trailer came out and doc ock just
smacks that car the car flips up and
over itself is like oh
that was pretty awesome and that's what
they do so well in this movie doc ock
when he's throwing down when he's
fighting spider-man when he's building
his machine he's doing so many things at
once he's like the ultimate multi-tasker
villain one of the arms is lightness
cigar he's building his machine it was
just optimal usage of this character sam
raimi definitely had a plan he's like no
i want to show doc och but i want to
show what someone can do they have four
mechanical arms welded to their back
also they're the reason for his
corruption so dr otto octavius to his
core isn't evil otto octavius was cool
he's bonding with peter parker you know
he's just a man of science he wanted to
help the world then these ai arms are
corrupting his brain
and that was i wasn't ready for that
when i watched this movie sam raimi's
direction and alfred molina's superb
acting they work together to bring this
character to life in a way i just never
thought possible they made more than a
spider-man villain they made a complex
character villain's just a title at this
point really he's a spider-man tragedy
this movie absolutely changed how i
viewed doc ock forever cherry on top
simple pleasures in this movie i love
that o.r horror movie scene you know
when the arms are just tearing these
doctors apart and sam raimi being like
okay i'm gonna go back to my horror
movie roots i just it's a pretty epic
scene but to its core spider-man 2 did
something unexpected
that is the thing that i think makes it
age well and that is it tells a
character story someone who's struggling
with their identity cause you look at
peter parker and why he became
spider-man peter parker became
spider-man out of this sense of
obligation you know with great power
comes great responsibility a lesson that
his uncle ben told him and when he
ignored that uncle ben died he was like
okay i can't have that happen to other
people plus uncle ben would want it this
way i have this power i have a
responsibility so now i'm spider-man but
the point is he's doing that for someone
else you know he's doing that out of a
sense of obligation to his uncle and his
lessons that'll get you on the saddle
absolutely but this movie takes it a
step further it has the guts to show
someone questioned whether or not they
should remain this superhero the fact
that it showed peter parker doubt this
he's struggling with himself you know he
has no sense of himself he has no sense
of him living his own life that will
make you question whether or not you
want to remain spider-man i love the
fact that this movie deals with that and
then
spider-man no more arc he gives it up
he's like all right done can we blame
him absolutely not it's another thing
sam raimi does really well the comic
books had a lot of comic books to show
how hard it is just to be peter parker
you know to balance this life of peter
parker and spider-man this movie's like
we don't have that much time so we
really need to show it in small under
two hours so there's not a lot of time
there i love the fact that sam raimi was
like we'll illustrate that by showing
all these instances where peter parker
just gets the shaft all these little
instances you ever feel like that you
ever feel like a bunch of little
annoyances that just chip away at you
are worse than one big thing happening
huh brother
yeah well peter parker's dealing with
all these little instances chipping away
at him also big things are happening
yeah this dude's absolutely gonna be
like i need to make my life easier i
need to minimize
[ __ ] it i'm out
simple life for me peter parker's back
baby spider-man no more and that right
there that core lesson that core human
experience that human lesson is the
reason spider-man 2
remains top tier for me the difference
between doing something for someone else
and feeling obligated and actually
living a life for yourself and showing
that coming of age arc where peter
parker is no longer spider-man out of
obligation to uncle ben he's spider-man
because he chooses to be the scene where
he goes in that burning building and
saves that little kid with no powers
whatsoever just shows that that's who he
is he's the person who helps people he
helps people because that's his core him
being spider-man by the end of this
movie he's no longer spider-man out of a
sense of obligation to his dead uncle
he's spider-man because that's his life
that he chooses for himself at least
that's how i assess it i feel like
there's a whole conversation that people
can have about this movie is whether or
not like well is that where peter
parker's mind is by the end of this
movie but that's how i see it and it's
very fulfilling for me you know it's
very layered i went into this movie
thinking okay we're gonna have a great
spider-man smash in time walked out of
spider-man 2 i remember being like it
was great i do need to unpack that
though there's a lot more there than i
actually thought i was signing on for
and that's why we love spider-man 2 and
that's why spider-man 2 is
awesome tacular
[Music]
[Applause]
i guarantee this is going to be one of
those videos that i upload i'm
immediately gonna be met with oh man i
should have talked about this i should
have talked about that that is where you
come in my friends i leave that to you
pick up where i failed anything i forgot
to talk about anything that hit you in
spider-man 2 that i didn't talk about
absolutely comment below talk about it
and i will answer your big question
right now before you ask it in the
comment section my personal favorite
spider-man movie for me yes it's
spider-man 2. and now's the part where i
send that lovely love to the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by squarespace truly the all-in-one
platform to build your online presence
and run your business buying a domain
from squarespace is simple no hidden
fees no price hikes you can present
videos from youtube vimeo and animoto on
your squarespace site as a person who
works with video it's important you can
use squarespace's professional portfolio
designs to present your professional
work professionally and i will always
love that every design automatically
comes with a unique mobile experience
that matches the overall style of your
website so go to squarespace.com for
your free trial and when you're ready to
launch click the link below go to
squarespace.com jeremyjohn save yourself
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain using promo code john's and
thank you once again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright so spider-man 2 have you seen it
what did you think about it what do you
love about spider-man 2 again that i
totally forgot to talk about because
there's a lot but whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you